la tournée courage devait marquer le
grand retour de Céline Dion après
plusieurs années en résidence à Las
Vegas sa première tournée planétaire
depuis takin il y a 15 ans et sa
première tournée mondiale depuis la mort
de René Angélil
mais rien ne s'est passé comme prévu dès
le début de sa tournée elle a dû à Lulli
quelques dates parce qu'elle était
atteinte de virus à la gorge ensuite les
reports et les annulations se sont
succédés à cause de la pandémie et pour
des raisons médicales elle vient
finalement d'annoncer qu'elle annuleait
tous les spectacles restants prévus pour
2023 2024 par voie de communiquer elle a
indiqué il vaut mieux tout annuler
maintenant jusqu'à ce que je sois
vraiment prête à remonter sur scène je
veux que vous sachiez que je n'abandonne
pas et que surtout j'ai très hâte de
vous revoir j'éprouve des problèmes de
santé depuis longtemps en décembre
dernier elle avait révélé qu'on lui
avait dit diagnostiqué une maladie rare
le syndrome de la personne red qui
provoque des spasmes musculaires graves
et persistants à l'époque le docteur
Stéphane boitier avait expliqué sur nos
ondes que des traitements existent mais
qu'il n'y a pas de cuir miracle il y a
des traitements qui permettent de
contrôler la maladie d'atténuer les
symptômes de se rapprocher le plus
possible d'une vie normale mais il n'y a
pas de traitement curatif
[Musique]
Céline Dion a expliqué travailler très
fort pour retrouver ses forces mais qui
est en donnait que les tournées sont
exigeantes et difficiles il lui
présentement impossible de se préparer
comme il se doit plutôt cette année les
fans de la star ont pu se consoler en la
voyant faire ses premiers pas au cinéma
dans le film love again en dépit des
critiques généralement très négatives le
film récolté plus de 10 millions de
dollars américains au box-office love
comme je
t'ai vu
tout remise sur pied je veux le meilleur
poêle et je vous trouve que elle pouvait
retourner à bientôt ça fait quand même 4
ans du coup qu'elle annule qu'elle
reprend qu'elle annule donc moi je sais
pas si vraiment un jour j'aurai
l'occasion de la voir en concert la
santé avant tout la santé
comme le titre tristement prémonitoire
de son album et de sa tournée le laisser
entendre il lui faudra du courage
[Musique]
si Nabil Alexandre Chartier Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]